this episode was made possible by
generous supporters on patreon
hey crazies there still seems to be some
confusion about how relativity works
before we do any more videos let's
straighten a few things out here are the
fundamental rules of relativity rules
that if 'ti now here are the rules you
should know rule number one no point of
view has preference over any other point
of view ever that's what it means for
things to be relative does the moon
orbit the earth or does it orbit the Sun
depends on your point of view both are
correct do the planets orbit the Sun in
circles or do they orbit the Sun and
spirals depends on your point of view
both are correct
does this squirrel accelerate toward the
ground or does the ground accelerate up
toward the squirrel it depends on your
point of view both are correct even
though two observers can and often do
disagree neither one of them is wrong
well as long as they're taking
measurements properly which brings me to
rule number two every observer carries
their own set of coordinates and their
own clock the real world has dimensions
and it's filled with paths and shapes
the things that we see around us look
geometric but geometry isn't a very
versatile form of math on its own so we
invented something called a coordinate
system a device that turns geometry into
algebra it's a way for us to label
positions with numbers and label
directions with signs we've already
established that no one's point of view
gets preference so everyone has their
own set of coordinates relative to
themselves and because this isn't just
about space it's also about time those
coordinates include a clock that
measures their personal time some people
call that proper time but there's
nothing proper about it don't forget
rule number one no one is proper
everyone's time is on equal footing it's
a terrible name so I'm not gonna use it
I do what I want the point is as long as
everyone is taking measurements using
their own coordinates and clock it
doesn't matter if they disagree it's
fine
rule number three if one observer wants
to take measurements for a different
observer
then they need a coordinate
transformation as the name suggests it
transforms one set of coordinates into
another for special relativity those are
called Lorentz transformations named
after Hendrik Lorentz because he came up
with the ones we use today Wow
Einstein gets a lot of credit for other
people's work huh for general relativity
the transformation depends on what the
geometry looks like around the Earth the
transformation for time looks something
like this time passes slower on the
surface than it does farther away in
space that looks like math is that
behalf I didn't sign up for any math yes
yes it's math but we're gonna try to
work around it consider two observers me
and you let's assume I'm in a space
station in the middle of empty space
because that happens to be exactly where
I am let's also assume you are at a
spaceship traveling it's a 55% the speed
of light that's best now let's remember
the rules
one no point of view has preference so
neither one of us is special in any way
but at least as far as space time is
concerned to every observer carries
their own set of coordinates and their
own clock that looks like this for the
two of us at least from my point of view
if I want to get an idea of what's
happening from your point of view
I need rule number three I need a
coordinate transformation physically
that transformation would look like this
now you're stationary and I'm the one
that's moving and according to rule
number one both points of view are
correct
both of these are equally correct
whenever you work with relativity you've
got two options you can do the hideous
math in all its glory which works but
isn't very interesting or insightful or
you can use a spacetime diagram to make
the math easier which is more profound
but you have to accept a couple weird
visual things if you haven't guessed yet
I'm a fan of the second option to draw
these space-time diagrams properly we
need another rule rule number four it
will always look to an observer as
though they are stationary in space just
to clarify it doesn't matter what you
think you're doing all that matters is
what it looks like
if you're in a car that's driving you
certainly have a concept that you're
moving because your experience tells you
that things like buildings can't move
but it doesn't look very different from
when you're sitting on the couch
watching TV it's the things around you
that look like they're moving in both
cases so what's that have to do with
space-time diagrams right right that's
where I was going with this let's go
back to you and me in space
here's your spaceship again traveling at
a steady 55 percent to speed of light if
we focus on that for a minute and give
it some coordinates that looks like this
but that's just a space diagram we want
to spacetime diagram so we add a time
axis and show the spaceship moving
through time as well this is your ship's
space time path my station space time
path is here notice that my path lines
up with the time axis that means these
coordinates are mine your time axis
lines up with your path in a spacetime
diagram a coordinate transformation is
just a rotation but there's something a
little weird happening here we've
observed that space and time share
similar but opposite behavior when the
time axis rotates the space axis rotates
but in the opposite direction these are
my coordinates and these are yours each
time axis is perpendicular to each space
axis including this one yes these are
perpendicular like I said things look a
little strange in space-time diagrams
but we can get some powerful insights
did you notice what happened with the
paths they didn't change the coordinates
changed but the paths stayed the same
rule number five space-time paths are
invariant under coordinate
transformations observers like you and
me might measure different amounts of
space or different amounts of time but
we all agree on the space-time path for
example let's say you started your
stopwatch here and stopped it here you
would say this much time had passed on
your clock using my own stopwatch I
would say this much time had passed and
I would say you went this far through
space we might disagree on the
coordinates and the time but we both
agree you took this path we just need a
coordinate
transformation to properly compare the
measurements and if we strictly obey
these rules we see some even weirder
things let's say this is the back of
your spaceship and this is the front now
let's say you have a light at each end
that blink at the same time like this
but I will not see them blink at the
same time for me those events happen at
different times I see the light blink
like this so we can disagree on how much
time is passed or how far your ship is
traveled or even how much space your
ship takes up for one observer distance
or time could even be zero but not both
if one observer says things happened at
the same place and time then that's just
one event and everyone agrees on that
all right so we may or may not disagree
on things depending in the situation but
there's always one final rule that we
can count on rule number six causality
must be maintained no matter what
causality also known as cause and effect
must hold for all observers if one event
causes another then we'll all agree they
happened in a particular order the cause
will always happen before the effect
different amounts of time before but
always before this is the rule that
limits the speed of light and frankly
the speed of anything that could cause
an event even if you think you've come
up with some clever scenario Conway 79
let's say I'm on my space station
observing two ships I see these ships
moving at 55% the speed of light in
opposite directions fast if we shift to
one of their points of view you might
think they observe the other ship moving
away at a hundred and ten percent the
speed of light but that would be
incorrect
remember rule number three we need the
coordinate transformation the
transformation between these two points
of view is not what you'd expect from
your personal experience the
transformations for velocity actually
looked like this ebook shameless
promotion ebook so one ship would
actually measure the other ship speed to
be 84.5% the speed of light which is
still less than the speed of light you
have to remember all the rules if you
want to work with relativity properly
rule number one no point of view has
preference over any other point of view
rule number two every observer carries
their own set of coordinates and their
own clock rule number three if one
observer wants to take measurements for
a different observer than they need a
coordinate transformation rule number
four it will always look to an observer
as though they are stationary in space
rule number five space-time paths are
invariant under coordinate
transformations in rule number six
causality must be maintained no matter
what those are the rules that space-time
lives by and we have to live with the
consequences even if they're weird
so got any questions of our relativity
please ask in the comments thanks for
liking and sharing this video don't
forget to subscribe if you'd like to
keep up with us and until next time
remember it's okay to be a little crazy
the featured comment comes from Jack
beaming tenue asked can light be
affected by gravity absolutely gravity
is space-time curvature so anything
traveling through space-time will be
affected by it even light thanks for
watching
[Music]